now we take you to the five things you
need to watch today number one it is the
big takeover in cable television charter
agreeing to buy time warner cable for 55
billion dollars there was a statement
moments ago from the Federal
Communications Commission saying the
following quote the FCC reviews every
merger on its merits and determines
whether it would be in the public
interest in applying the public interest
test and absence of harm is not
sufficient Commission will look to see
how American consumers would benefit if
the deal were to be approved so
Stephanie this is a bit of tom wheeler
talking out of both sides of his mouth
on the one hand he picks up the phone
and calls tom rutledge the senior as
we're open for business you know we're
not saying you'll make it not open for
business but deal-making welcome and
then finally we see the deal and tom
wheeler strikes a bit of a different
tone that's what doesn't work maybe this
is wheeler just saying what he has to
say is chairman of the FCC we have to
review every deal we have to make sure
that it's in the best interest of the
American people I think so think so
because had he not couldn't one make the
argument hold on he makes a completely
out of character Public Hall last week
calling guys saying no no think about it
we're fine with it and then to let the
deal simply go through I don't know I
don't think that would have gone so well
he's got to make a statement like this
you know I've got to keep up appearances
okeydoke he does have that number two
that's what I've got the strong dollar
the US dollar jumped to an almost eight
year high against the yen the dollar
strengthened up following fed reserve
chairwoman Janet yellen's remarks on
Friday saying it wouldn't be appropriate
to raise rates this year if the economy
improves and Eric that's what this dance
is all about trying to get a sense how
strong the economy really is and when
they can actually make this move when
you speak two bowls they say it could
have happened a year ago but the more
and more people we talked to in the
market who are so addicted to the
support they're getting from central
bank's they love to say no things are
really fragile I am growing I'm sure you
are too a little bit tired of this
guessing game I'm going to I'm gonna
channel Stanley Fischer right it's not
about the date it's about the data it's
not really about when it's how fast they
raise interest rates for the Bears when
the first 25 basis-point height comes
it's when the next 75 or 100
25 come at matter it's not about the
data it's about the data but if Michael
McKee were here he would say to us there
are so many data points depending on who
you're speaking to that individual
decides well this data matters I know
that one no it doesn't the jobs number
will forget it that doesn't factor in X
Y or Z so I just think you know
everybody's talking their books surprise
surprise all right number three Julie
Hyman let's take a look at what's going
on with stocks today expensive you could
say is the new cheap banks now appear to
be the least expensive industry on the
sp500 but guys it's all relative their
training at seventeen point six times
trailing earnings the S&P overall is
trading at 18.8 only once has the
cheapest sector in the SP commanded a
higher valuation than 17.6 in other
words cheap ain't that cheap sure I mean
welcome to the bull market I mean I just
if you look at how well companies are
doing S&T companies this was you know
Carl icons argument if you would just
invest in the SP a lot of these
companies aren't superstars people are
just investing to take the ride so you
like beta better than alpha listen if
you actually look at fundamentals look
at the tech industry look at the
valuations you've talked about it they
give out Shake Shack a restaurant yes it
may be delicious but a burger place with
seven menu items crazy crazy town but
they're saying guess what we might serve
chicken sandwiches now that that'll
really give reason for the ridiculous
valuation all right I have number four
or Quatro in Spanish we have got the
data to watch today we're just talking
about the importance of all that durable
goods numbers come out in about 30
minutes we've also got case-shiller home
prices at 9am Eric it's about what data
do you care about I'm not sure durable
goods is at the top of my list I am it
case-shiller is a bit of a lagging
indicator but I'm fascinated to see all
the same you know where we are in the
home price recovery whether we're I'd
like to see if anybody I'd like to see
if anybody's gonna take down at five
hundred million dollar house and Ellen
we're not gonna get that at eight-thirty
I'm just saying that's the number i want
to see all right number five everybody's
gonna invite me over via chairs
look at these down following a New York
Times report the General Motors rejected
ser yo Marconi's overture to discuss a
merger Marconi has been an outspoken
since last year in fact about the need
for consolidation in the auto industry
for there to be global companies
fiat-chrysler big company number three
here in America as far as Marconi's
concerned not big enough of course he's
not again talking his book if you're
Marconi that's what you want a big
business difference though is is that we
had heard so he first raised this idea
in the past and we had heard from people
close to fiat that other automakers
including Ford and General Motors had
expressed no interest we had not known
until now thanks to the New York Times
that Marconi actually wrote out in long
form in an email to Mary Barra his
desire to complete a merger usually she
didn't even grant him a meeting she
didn't know you know the automaker CEO
that matters to me most rolls-royce CEO
who told Eric and I he doesn't feel
threatened by elon musk and the
driverless cars they've had driverless
cars for decades a century in fact
called the chauffeur